un año del inicio de la última guerra en
europa y este 27 de septiembre las
conmemoraciones sustituyeron los
bombardeos en azerbaiyán el presidente
ilham alíyev participó en una marcha de
celebración los azeríes apoyados por
turquía recuperaron tras 44 días de
conflicto parte de nagorno karabaj
además de siete distritos adyacentes el
20 por ciento del país que pertenecía a
armenia desde la anterior guerra que
duró de 1992 a 1994
la segunda guerra de karabaj es nuestra
gloriosa historia esta victoria
permanecerá en la historia para siempre
del otro lado armenia vivió el lunes una
ofrenda floral liderada por el primer
ministro niccoló para xinjiang en el
cementerio militar del albur antes el
domingo más de 3000 armenios convocados
por la oposición marcharon con antorchas
mientras haya un vecino como azerbaiyán
con esa mentalidad creo que el conflicto
está inconcluso
un conflicto inacabado que llega a las
secuelas sicológicas vigentes entre los
soldados de azerbayán hijo que mi sueño
suelo veo a mis amigos soldados
martirizados y uno de ellos siempre está
gritando pero también en los armenios
cuando regrese a casa comencé a sentirme
nervioso maldito comencé a tener
insomnio y recurrir a los psicólogos
para que me ayudaran de ser la guerra
finalizó el 10 de noviembre tras la
firma de una tregua auspiciada por moscú
en el conflicto del cáucaso sur murieron
más de 6000 personas además de
acusaciones cruzadas de crímenes de
guerra ante la corte internacional de
justicia fue la última de las batallas
después de las disputas de 1988 el año
2000 y la guerra de los cuatro días de